on the other hand let me hasten to add
that
that doesn't make us small or
make the time that we have to us
small because uh again looking at those
pictures of
you know what our minds are in some
sense of components of our minds these
beautiful drawings of the cellular
patterns inside the brain
you see that there are many many many
processing units
and if you analyze how fast they operate
i try to estimate how many thoughts a
person can have in a lifetime that's
kind of a fuzzy question but i'm very
proud that i
i was able to define it pretty precisely
and it turns out we can we have time for
billions
of meaningful thoughts you know in a
lifetime
so so it's a lot we shouldn't we
shouldn't think of ourselves as terribly
small
either in space or in time because
although we're
small in those dimensions compared to
the universe where
we're large compared to
meaningful units of processing
information
and and being able to conceptualize and
understand things
yeah but 99 of those thoughts are
probably
food sex or internet related but yeah
well they're not
that's right only like point one is
nobel prize winning ideas
but that's true but uh you know there's
more to life than winning nobel prizes
how did you um do that calculate can you
maybe break that apart a little bit just
kind of
for fun sort of an intuition of how we
calculate the number of thoughts
the number of thoughts right there
they're it's it's necessarily imprecise
because a lot of things are going on in
different ways and what is a thought
but there are several things that point
to more or less the same
rate of being able to have meaningful
thoughts
for instance the one that i think is
maybe the most
penetrating is how fast we can
we can process visual images how to how
do we do that
uh if you've ever
watched old movies you can see that that
when well any movie in fact that in a
motion picture is really not a motion
picture it's
a series of snapshots that are playing
one after the other
and it's the because our brains
also work that way we take snapshots of
the world
integrate over a certain time and then
go on to the next one and then
by post-processing create the illusion
of continuity and flow
uh we can deal with that and uh
the if the flicker rate is too slow
then you start to see that it's not it's
a series of snapshots
and you can ask what is the what is the
crossover when does it change from being
something that
that is matched to our processing speed
versus
too fast and and it turns out about 40
per second
and then if you take 40 per second as
as how well we how fast we can process
visual images you get
to several billions of thoughts uh
if you similarly if you uh ask
what what are some of the fastest things
that people can do well you can they can
play video games they can play the piano
very fast if
if they're skilled at it and again you
get to similar
uh units or how fast can people talk you
get to sim
you know within a couple of orders of
magnitude you get more or less to the
same
idea so uh so that's how
you can say that that there's there's
billions of
meaning there's room for billions of
meaningful thoughts
yeah i won't argue for exactly 2 billion
versus 1.8 billion it's not that kind of
question but
but i think any estimate that's
reasonable will come out
within say 100 billion and 100 million
so
it's a lot it would be interesting
to map out for an individual human being
the landscape of thoughts that they've
sort of traveled if you think of
thoughts as a set of trajectories
uh what what that landscape looks like i
mean
i've been recently really thinking about
uh
this richard dawkins idea of memes
and just all this ideas and the
evolution of ideas inside of one
particular human mind
and how there's there then changed and
evolved by
interaction with other human beings it's
interesting to think about
so if you think the numbers billions
you you think there's also social
interaction so these aren't
uh like there's interaction in the same
way you have interaction with particles
there's interaction between human
thoughts
uh that are perhaps that's that
interaction in itself is fundamental to
the process
of thinking like without social
interaction we would be
like stuck like walking in a circle we
need
we need the perturbation of other humans
to create
change in evolution once you bring in
concepts of uh
interactions and correlations and
relations
then you have what's called a
combinatorial explosion
that the number of possibilities rap
expands exponentially technically with
the number of
the number of things you're considering
and
uh it can easily rapidly outstrip these
these billions of thoughts that we're
talking about so
we we definitely uh cannot by brute
force
master complex situations and
or think about think of all the
possibilities in a complex situations i
mean you know
even even something as relatively simple
as chess
is still something that human beings
can't comprehend completely even the
best players lose
still sometimes lose and they
consistently lose to computers these
days
uh and in computer science there's a
concept of
np complete so large classes of problems
when you scale them up beyond
a few individuals become intractable
and so that in that sense uh the world
is inexhaustible
but and that makes it beautiful that we
can make uh
any laws that generalize
uh efficiently and well can compress all
of that
combinatorial complexity just like a
simple rule that that itself is
beautiful it's a happy situation and
i i think that that we can
find general principles of
sort of of the operating system that
are comprehensible simple extremely
powerful and let us control
things uh very well and and ask profound
questions
and on the other hand that the world is
going to be inexhaustible
that once we start asking about
relationships and how they evolve
and social interactions and the the
the will never have a theory of
everything in any meaningful sense
because of everything everything
truly everything is
you